Vsauce on Wednesday a lot of you guys
were asking for a new episode of up all
night our technical pranks and
curiosities show unfortunately these
guys are still on vacation but I'm gonna
try to do this alone let's go to begin
you can break into locked luggage just
by poking it with a pen and :
but let's get more digital to secretly
view websites while at work or school
you can use vanished comm it covers what
you're doing with something innocuous
like google.com or a spreadsheet but by
scrolling your mouse wheel up and down
you can open and close a little viewing
window that lets you take a peek at what
you're really viewing the next time one
of your friends leaves themselves logged
into Facebook click on account settings
and go in the language now don't pick a
weird language pick something subtle
like English upside down now whenever
they log into Facebook and wherever they
log into Facebook some of the words will
be flipped another fun trick if your
friend has a Mac is to switch a simple
keyboard shortcut to something
ridiculous for instance let's make the
keyboard shortcut to invert colors
command C that way the next one tries to
do something simple like copy and paste
this happens and if you haven't seen it
yet enter your home's address into this
Arcade Fire html5 video and see what
happens a few episodes ago we showed you
some JavaScript that lets you edit a
website but with Google Chrome you can
take it one step further the explanation
for this is kind of long but basically
what I can do is on my machine
booby-trap a YouTube page so that when
someone tries to leave a comment YouTube
tells them that their past comments have
violated u.s. criminal code and their
name has been submitted to the FBI
pretty sweet
crush bits com is a hilarious way to
prank your friends the site
unfortunately has a lot of popups so
just close anything that doesn't look
like what you see on the screen first
type in your name I don't know a fake
birthdate and an email address I'm going
to use Michael from the office at male
innate or calm because you can just make
up anything at mail innate or calm and
get those emails without needing a
password and without giving out your
real email address now I trade the code
that give me to a friend and tell them
that the site ism
amazing a determining if there secret
crush likes them so let's say I give it
to Jake and he says oh boy I don't want
anyone to know this but I have a crush
on Patti Smith Tarzan and the pink Power
Ranger why hope no one finds out and I
hope this site tells me they like me
wait what my answers have been email to
Michael Stevens and sure enough I can go
to male inator type in Michael Stevens
from the office and view the email with
no password and yep Jake admitted to
liking Patti Smith Tarzan and the pink
Power Ranger nice this next trick
requires Photoshop and is pretty
involved but it's fun to watch basically
I'm going to hide a message in a song
first I start with an mp3 this one is
the key of Awesome's electronic was now
first I change its extension to dot R aw
and now I open the file with Photoshop
or some other image editor that supports
RAW files I'll tell it to guess the
right size and tada I get a visual
representation of all the digital
information in the song now I can write
my secret message the password is donkey
pizza and then save as Photoshop raw now
I go back to this file and I can change
the extension back to mp3 so that when
people see it it plays just like normal
though in the middle where the code is
it's creepy space-alien messy stuff I
can trade this mp3 to friends who know
the secret and when they change the
extension back to raw and open in
Photoshop they get to see the code so
there you go a lot of those were super
technical but I hope you had fun be sure
to subscribe to vsauce for more
information videos and as always thanks
for watching